[Music]  i've been dreaming about this in my life  and the giant's gold it's the biggest  treasure that's never been found five  billion easy  so when do we start yeah put that in  your head  hello hello i can hear him sitting right  next to you  your brother believed that there was a  final piece  but you know my brother's there what  else aren't you telling me  you have no idea who you partnered with  it's gonna take a little longer than i  thought kid  i assume we're 50 50 right  50 50. you get 10 that's me being  generous wow  let's play some parachutes what unless  you know a better way to jump out of a  plane  oh my god i'm so sorry  come on  500 years ago my family found the  vulture  and was betrayed  so much blood  you're doing great  this ain't over  hey you still with me  barely  what's with the cat she's just real what  life seems super sad i'm not gonna keep  this thing exclusively a movie theater  [Music]  you